how am I feeling Oh hmm I feel okay not
sponsored not even a huge fan as a brand
just cleaned shirt to wear at the house
hi guys welcome to this video my name is
grace Helbig if you did not know now you
know my voice is a few octaves lower
than it used to be because I was at a
Comedy Festival and things were loud and
I was trying to talk over music to have
conversations with people and now I
sound like I've eaten a box of
cigarettes so sexy sexy cigarettes
though it's time for July favorites
these are the things that I've liked
slightly more than the other things in
my life throughout the month of July one
thing that's not on this list is
showering Oh kudos to all of you that
I've enjoyed showering thoroughly for
the month of July and also fall deeply
quick TMI scenario I haven't shaved my
armpits for a time all right before this
video I realized I was wearing a
sleeveless shirt and so I maybe should
do that and I didn't have a lady razor
here but in my cabinet I found a men's
facial shaver device like a vibrator
meets a knife that has a battery and you
turn it on and I used it on my armpits
it seemed fine but now things are
feeling stinky I regret it so if I'm
doing this it's not because I love
dancing it's because my armpits are on
fire let's get into my favorites for the
month of July right July oh my god it's
August okay yeah yes yeah yes yeah yeah
yeah this is the forest dry clean
instant dry brush cleaner spray more
words please I'm awful at cleaning my
makeup brush absolutely awful they're
all just little fluffy dumpsters because
I never clean them ever ever ever I
bought this when I was in line at
Sephora in that section that they have
when you wait in line for the cash
registers is that area that has all the
stuff that is just like why not this was
a why not purchase I've used it once
through all my brushes and it's awesome
miss they spray it on your brushes and
then you take a paper towel and you just
sort of like dab your brush and if you
were someone that right
really cleaned your brushes you could
probably just get away with doing this
once or twice I had to do it probably
eight nine ten times on each brush I
have but one this smells amazing - it
really gets rid of so much [ __ ] that's
on your brushes and three they stay dry
so you can use them right after the
hardest part for me is when I realize
that my brushes are dirty I clean them
but then I have to wait for like 12
hours until they dry completely and I
can use them again and life just sucks
so this helps life suck a little less
yeah yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah
yeah say this is body perfect but
perfect is spelled ERF ekt this was also
a white of not purchase at Sephora
when I was checking out basically it's a
tinted Body Gel / lotion that's not
supposed to transfer I used it the other
day when I had to go to a thing that
people were at I was running late and I
hadn't used a self-tanner and so I just
decided to go for this and when I
squeezed it out onto my hands I thought
oh no this is an awful awful mistake cuz
look ready oh my god I'm doing beauty
guru that looks like a Pidgey diarrhea
into my hand right I was like oh no it's
all dried out and I got an old bottle of
it but then when you do this it glides
on so smooth but it's just a very nice
smooth finish do you respect me more now
because I'm body perfect it just goes on
incredibly incredibly smooth and is very
very subtle and does not transfer onto
your clothing so if you have an event
that people are attending and you just
want that extra subtle help to make your
skin look like plastic this is really
great yeah yeah yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah I showed you this in a video
recently this is Tarte slip facial it's
basically a lip scrub in a tube and you
just put it on your lips and it scrubs
them and it's fantastic I know that you
can make lip scrubs at home super super
easily and there's a billion videos that
show you how to do that but when you're
traveling it's a little bit more
difficult to do that so this is really
awesome it's really convenient to travel
with it tastes
delicious and if you're someone like me
and is wildly dehydrated all the time
it's a really nice thing to have on hand
something that makes your lips look like
lips and not like crusty white Alaskan
glaciers fun next yeah yes say yeah say
yeah yeah say yeah this is a product I
also talked to you recently about in the
video get ready with me for real video I
think I talked to you about this this is
Smashbox photo-finish lash primer
it's basically a white mascara look at
this beauty guru nonsense that's
happening you put it on your eyelashes
before you put on your actual mascara
and it just helps the mascara look ager
better bolder braver it's like that daft
punk's on for your eyelashes max yeah
say yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah
hearts Park Avenue princess bronze &
Glow because what's better than living
on Park Avenue living on Park Avenue and
being King royalty no that's kind of my
worst nightmare is the thing that
happened last night I had a dream that I
owned a fluffy white sloth whose name
was Ellis and she spoke English and she
was just like super curious about my
life and so she kept climbing on my
shoulders and we kept walking around to
different areas of my house and there
were other people around she was
interacting with my dog and it was um I
woke up feeling weird tartes Park Avenue
princess bronze & Glow I've had for a
while but I only recently started using
it's basically this liquid bronzer in
this end and then the cat watch this
beauty guru nun so the cap is a creamy
blush numb wearing both of them today
super easy to travel with just is really
great for the summer makes you look like
someone that enjoys the Sun the actual
outdoor Sun like someone that feels
confident enough to leave their house
and be in the Sun someone that just does
not feel the anxiety and total
paralyzing paranoia of what it's like to
leave the safety of their own home and
experience the actual the Sun so for
those of you that don't do that here's
this neck this can't see ya hi I'm say
hi update this is
on angry day hearts quench lip rescue
I'm wearing this right now this is in
the color nude and it's basically a
lipgloss stick that's also super
hydrating to your lips I like it a lot
packagings cute easy to travel with and
the combo of these two things together I
think is really good these come in a lot
of different colors it's not a stain or
anything but super easy to reapply super
sheer very moisturizing cetera etc
hasn't made my lips fall off my face so
can't say bad things about it next this
yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah this is
a Kevin Kwan palette it's called the
contour book vol 2 it's got all of these
things in it Wow there are contouring
colors and highlighting colors and
there's a cream and a shadow for each
one depending on what you like and I've
recently tried both of these contouring
cream and shadows and I like both of
them very much there's also all these
beautiful eye shadow colors this white
one is wonderful it's called Brighton
which is really what it does it makes my
face look bright
ah then it actually is because I haven't
been sleeping well lately you can tell
by this moment in this video but then
also there's all these instructions
guides for how to best sculpt and where
the powders and stuff that's inside of
this I appreciate that
yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah yeah
say yeah this is the security system I
might be talking to the wrong audience
about this but this is something I've
enjoyed recently and ah maybe some of
you might be interested in it I don't
know if any of you out there have an
overly healthy amount of paranoia in to
the point that it's unhealthy amount of
paranoia in you when you're home by
yourself about being kidnapped
this is the product for you so these are
security cameras so wire free outdoor
security camera and I also have a
doorbell that is a camera that's built
in with the motion sensor from ring is
the brand ring and you can download an
app on your phone and basically it'll
alert you when there's motion that goes
by your camera you can see it in real
time but you can also go back and watch
it later if you weren't able to catch it
on your phone in that moment they work
really well the video quality is pretty
decent I'm not well versed in the
security camera world of things so maybe
there are better products but for me as
someone that is an idiot um these are
pretty straightforward and easy to use
though one don't be here come to my
house because I can see you do if you
also don't meet with this is I found
that this is a good brand for security
cameras also it can connect to your
iCloud account so you can save any
recordings that you might need to save
there's that I don't know I just thought
world is a terrible place so we're all
trying to do the best we can put me on
to something that's less tape yeah yeah
yeah these are Tostitos tortilla chips
with a hint of lime I love these very
much my step mom used to buy these when
I was younger and that's how I was first
introduced to them and I never
understood why she got the ones that had
a flavor on them but then all of a
sudden it was a very very delightful
pleasing flavor that I needed to have
more oven I haven't bought them for a
while but recently over the last couple
weeks I've been buying a lot of them and
I think they are delicious so if you're
looking to spice up your tortilla chip
life try hint of lime this is like a sad
favorites now oh yeah there's nothing
sad about being an adult trying to
convince other people why the lime
flavored tortilla chips are better than
right um is that it I think that's it
thank you guys for watching this video
if you enjoyed this video or if you
hated it at all please subscribe to this
youtube channel because it's just you
know not the worst experience in your
whole life
and there's no other thing to add to
this so I don't know
yeah sorry I'm trying to make my makeup
look not gross because everything I keep
around is disgusting I'm just trying to
paint the portrait that I am everything
is put together in my life I am very
very capable okay this